alors justement maintenant il va falloir
établir les responsabilités l'homme la
machine le système
quelle est la part de chacun de ces
facteurs le train qui arrivait de melun
avait déjà vous l'avez entendu été
victime d'un incident technique qui
mettait en jeu les freins plus tard le
conducteur avait t-il le moyen de
prévenir la gare quand son train est
devenu fou ou encore vous demandez
peut-être ne peut-on interrompre plus ou
moins brutalement bien sûr un train qui
est à propulsion électrique
nous allons reparler des problèmes de la
sécurité avec les premières réactions
des syndicats
et cette première question toutefois
est-il possible d'assurer une sécurité
totale en tout cas dans cette
catastrophe
il y a bien eu défaillance patrick
esther hier soir vers 18h55 sur la voie
numéro deux de la gare souterraine de
paris lyon le train pour villeneuve
saint georges est à quai un autre train
parti de melun se dirige au même instant
vers paris lorsque cette rame de
banlieue arrive à proximité de vert de
maisons
un passager va tirer le signal d'alarmé
ce qui entraîne l'arrêt automatique de
la ram acte de malveillance probable
dire à la direction de la sncf
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à cet instant là
les freins fonctionne parfaitement pour
réenclencher le système
le conducteur doit même descendre de la
motrice puis lemelin paris repart il est
à 8 km du terminus son trajet est suivi
par le poste de régulation de paris sud
est
le conducteur aperçoit un premier signal
jaune mais la vitesse est réduite
il sait qu'il peut facilement arrêter le
train si le feu suivant est au rouge
et effectivement le feu suivant est au
rouge
le conducteur déclenché les freins ceci
ne répondent pas il ne reste plus que
six cents mètres avant l'entrée en gare
il prévient par radio le poste de
régulation il sait déjà que dans trente
secondes son train va percuter quelque
part devant lui il reste beaucoup
d'aiguillage pour dévier le train fou
mais les aiguilleurs n'ont que quelques
secondes pour choisir un nouvel
itinéraire
ils doivent éviter de faire se percuter
deux convois en marche et qui sont
nombreux à cette heure d'affluence
ils doivent aussi éviter d'envoyer le
convoi vers la
art aérienne le train en défonçant les
butoir pourrait tuer des centaines de
personnes dans le hall le sort est joué
lemelin paris se dirige vers la voie
numéro deux de la gare souterraine où le
pari villeneuve saint georges en retard
sur l'horaire est encore inquiet à 60
kilomètres/heure
la maîtrise a percuté et perforer la
ramie mobile en broyant les malheureux
passagers
[Musique]